the time for social distancing its
immediate late what exactly is social
distancing social distancing Institute
more social distancing my name is
karellen canoe CEO and I'm a social
epidemiologist every action that we take
and every way in which we can hold back
from the public sphere in order to limit
the opportunities for transmission is an
opportunity truly to save a life I'm
wondering if there are just one or two
concrete pieces of advice you would want
people to follow I think our lives
should look radically different right
now than they normally do I would say
limit your face-to-face interactions
work remotely whenever possible no
handshakes no high-fives no hugs
outside the home stand six feet or more
away from any person you're encountering
in a public space and severely restrict
your travel from city to city limiting
that to truly urgent matters and limit
your engagement in the public sphere
don't attend group gatherings don't go
to the theater don't go to sporting
events what we're trying to prevent is
contact with droplets when people sneeze
cough or spit I'm wondering what you
think of small social gatherings
how big is too big you will get
different answers from different people
about this and I tend to be more
conservative one of my son said to me
mom if we're quarantined at least we can
still have dinner parties right and I
said no Gabriel that's the antithesis of
what quarantine is about we have to
minimize our contact with others I would
say that's the general rule limited
limited to what's necessary do you
recommend that people go outside even if
they have limited contact with people so
what I've been doing is trying to wake
up at a very early hour and go usually
or to go in very unpopulated places and
walk
I'm wondering what you think about
taking flights an important
consideration is that the movement of
populations is the fuel for continued
spread so in the 1918 flu there was this
massive movement of troops across the
United States and that troop movement
was the perfect vehicle for continuing
the spread of influenza and you may
think that it's different if you're just
traveling for spring break but really
there isn't any difference between that
kind of movement for the purposes of
wartime personnel needs and the movement
of people because they want to get to
the beach we don't want to have
prolonged contact with other humans in a
confined space and what's a flight if
not prolonged contact with other humans
than a confined space so don't do it
if you don't have to do it don't do it
I'm sure that's gonna be your answer for
all of the following questions I have if
you don't have to don't do it what about
public transportation so many people are
dependent upon public transit to get to
work there might be some risk reduction
practices people could adopt such as
trying to ride at off-peak times if you
are able to walk or ride your bike do
that it probably is safer from a an
infection perspective to drive one's own
car rather than to use public transit
but every public health person hates
saying that how should we approach
caring for elderly or at-risk neighbors
or people in our community who may need
help if people have been living with an
elderly family member they should reduce
radically their contact with the outside
world especially the primary caregiver
that's ultra important for elders who
are able to take care of their own
activities of daily living like my mom
lives independently she's taking the CDC
advice very seriously to stay at home
and we also make a point to call her
multiple
throughout the day my daughter in the
evening will read a story to my mom my
mom will read a story to her we play
games together over Google Hangouts we
really want to have ways to continue to
show her how much we love her and when
will this end when will we know that we
can stop social distancing I can't give
you a date when it will end
it would be good if we could have that
date because it would be reassuring to
people to know that this won't last
forever and it won't last forever but
it's probably going to be an
uncomfortably long period of time is
there a happy medium between extreme
social isolation and just keeping a
healthy distance from people so this
will be a very hard time for many people
and I would say that the happy medium is
to try to think creatively about ways to
engage socially without physically being
present call more often FaceTime more
often sing with friends out the windows
as people have been doing in Italy play
music for your loved ones over the phone
let your elders hear the voices of their
grandchildren over the phone give to
food banks give to homeless outreach
organizations if you're able to be
generous now is the time to be generous
and be generous not just with our
material gifts but also truly believe
deep in your heart that by stepping out
of the social realm right now you are
doing one of the greatest services you
can do to the public's health
[Music]